i'm so happy you guys are all together
hey how you doing
hi how are you
i'm good so i'm a huge fan of horror
films and i was so impressed with how
creepy this season is no on a scale of
one to ten how scary do you think season
four stranger things is
oh definitely an 11 i mean it's just
scary
it's definitely exceeded my expectations
with how scary they could go
it's it's definitely crazy
did you do the 11 on purpose have you
been doing this all day
[Laughter]
very well done um charlie how much fun
has it been for you kind of you know
exploring these horror elements with
this season
um yeah this season was super fun uh we
we got to shoot in a different location
so we were shooting in albuquerque new
mexico so um
it really yeah it felt like we were on a
different show all season uh
and um
yeah it was cool
okay so we know that jonathan and nancy
are trying the whole long distance thing
hard thing to do
it seems like there's a little bit of
trouble in paradise how much are you
rooting for these two to stick together
yeah um you know it's funny we we saw
where they they left off last season and
there was kissing there was like this
promise to be together but distance is
hard and i think distance is kind of
making them you know it's definitely
throwing them in to an um kind of an
unsure phase um
how much do i want them to be together
yeah uh you know i mean i love i think
you know i love jonathan and i think
nancy and jonathan have really sweet
moments i guess
yeah so you do root for them um
but i guess
yeah i guess we'll see we'll see we'll
see what happens in paradise we'll see
what happens well listen while nancy's
away jonathan has argyle
edwards
so funny how uh much fun has it been for
you joining this cast and playing this
character because i keep giggling
i appreciate you thank you um
hey dude it's been it's been an honor
man it's amazing to be a part of
something that's so
uh
uh you know like so uh
uh
just like
it's a culture you know it's crazy it's
like
it's an awesome thing to be a part of it
and like and like with the utmost
respect you know it's just like okay i'm
i'm a new guy i gotta you know i gotta
come here and i gotta do my thing and i
gotta make sure and knowing like that's
that was like so like
so much that i was bracing for like
ahead of time just because i'm always
like that
in my head and uh everybody was so
not like that everyone was like oh yeah
what's up bro like let's hang out you
know everybody was so welcoming and so
thoughtful and
and uh it's a it's an honor to be a part
of it i love it you know the whole
family the whole buyer's family's moved
to california so it's new beginnings for
a lot of people but how would you tease
the way 11 is fitting in with this new
place yeah i mean
i just like yeah she's she's kind of
struggling to fit in as any awkward
teenager would and it's just
will's kind of like very protective over
her and like a brother to her making
sure that she's getting through it but i
think it's nice and it's very relatable
and easy to connect to for the fans when
they watch
amazing um i'm being serious like the
first four episodes really freaked me
out i can't wait for everyone to see
this so thanks so much guys
thank you thank you